peu importe people MX ça ça m'intéresse
Alexandra Lamy dénonce le sexisme dont
elle a été victime êtes-vous d'accord
avec ses propos et j'aimerais avoir
votre avis aussi parce que les langues
se délient et hallucinant donc regardez
c'était dans l'émission avec gland de la
housse
qui lui demandait si elle était victime
de sexisme quand elle était jeune s'il y
avait des mains sur la cuisse pour
travailler un petit peu vrai ou faux
lors de l'une de vos premières
interviews il y a une vingtaine d'années
25 ans vous vous pose la question si
vous avez couché pour réussir est-ce que
c'est une réalité on vous posez ce type
de questions encore à l'époque
c'était encore les années un peu
enfin sans rentrer dans les détails mais
il y avait un peu le côté Oran une
petite main par là c'est pas bien grave
je tiens pardon mais il y avait un peu
de ça en étant les années où c'était pas
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il y a eu
ce combat aussi de se dire bah non en
fait quand on parle de consentement
quand on parle de tout ça effectivement
mais ça ça quand même j'espère de plus
en plus évolué ça m'intéresse vraiment
de savoir parce que d'abord ça arrive
aussi chez des garçons gays et des
chroniqueurs gays et ça peut arriver
aussi mais les hétéros voilà et chez les
filles j'aimerais avoir votre avis
Sophie notamment
des choses à dire Isa aussi Magalie
est-ce que vous vous avez déjà vécu des
choses comme ça par exemple toi oui moi
j'avais un boss qui m'appelait poulette
[Musique]
moi j'apprécie pas particulièrement
qu'on m'appelle par un nom de volaille
on est devenu amis
effectivement parfois c'est arrivé ce
qui me dérange le plus moi je trouve le
plus sexiste en fait en télévision et
surtout en radio c'est la disparité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
la co-animation bah oui mais c'est non
mais c'est pas un autre sujet
par exemple bien dîner à la maison tu
auras peut-être une émission un
producteur un jour je me souviens je
commençais sur M6 j'étais vraiment jeune
je vais avoir 20 ans et tout à l'époque
et euh
et oui je me suis retrouvé à côté d'un
producteur qui a dit tiens mais là à
côté de moi machin etc genre de choses
mais après je pense que ça dépend aussi
de l'attitude qu'on a moi j'ai
l'impression en tout cas que je ne
je projette pas genre de chose
est fermée elle est fermée
Isa alors je n'ai pas couché pour
réussir c'est pas la question qui est
mais si on me l'a proposé ben oui n + P
fois
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas assez une blague de comment on
peut te le proposer c'est une blague que
ce soit arrivé on t'as vraiment proposé
de demander de coucher les citrons
très très souvent des producteurs des
journalistes des chefs de service oui
mais
d'autres d'autres journal d'autres
organes si je veux dire
c'est un déjeuner c'est une dis pas que
j'ai avec moi c'est c'est effectivement
un déjeuner et puis après c'est plus
c'est affinités
avec un
homme extrêmement important dont je ne
dirais évidemment pas le nom donc c'est
sorti il m'a dit mais où vous allez où
tu vas je dis bah je rentre à VSD et il
m'a dit ah mais moi j'avais prévu autre
chose et il me montre l'hôtel à côté non
il me manque l'hôtel à côté et moi je
rentre j'éclate de rire parce que je
suis cette génération où on éclate de
rire quand on sait pas quoi dire je
rentre à VSD et j'avais repéré le nom de
l'hôtel j'appelle et je dis vous avez
une chambre réservée au nom de un thème
disons non et je dis ah est-ce que vous
avez une chambre réservée au nom de
Morini Bosc et ils me disent oui le mec
en plus
vous faire payer en plus c'est
incroyable
moi je peux pas vous dire qui n'est rien
ni quoi mais j'ai déjà eu aussi il y a
des animateurs qui sont gay aussi ça te
ramène en voiture le soir et tout d'un
coup elle m'a sur la cuisse tu as fait
une très belle émission tu as machin il
y a aussi des filles je me rappelle très
bien
et moi je me souviens j'avais à l'époque
un producteur qui était très en mais
alors vraiment un des plus gros
producteurs de télévision qui faisait un
appel d'offres pour une grosse émission
sur une grosse chaîne et il me dit j'ai
vu défiler des nanas dans mon bureau
dont des filles qu'on connaît très très
bien non je ne dirais pas le nom qui
arrivait dans le bureau avec la jupe et
pas de culotte et qui fait des petits
ronds un peu comme la tenue là c'est pas
la même chose pardon mais c'est
exactement la même chose parce que la
question c'était ce qui est des femmes
qui profitent de leur pouvoir c'est pas
pareil on voit le producteur qui est là
dernière anecdote dernière anecdote de
toute façon on est dans un métier de
séduction moi le premier quand j'allais
voir un producteur pour travailler à la
télé je savais qu'il était gay forcément
je me mettais un peu sexy un peu beau je
me mettais dans ce qu'il allait dire
comment ben c'est-à-dire je me mettais
un peu le torse voilà ouvert je me
mettais sexy pour essayer d'avoir la
place voilà moi aussi j'ai allumé c'est
une grosse allumeuse et puis parfois j'y
allais alors
[Applaudissements]
et j'ai eu des plaques merci Benoît tu
en as fait assez pour cette séquence la
dernière ici merci moi ça m'arrive aussi
quand j'étais marié j'étais très très
jeune je dis c'était mon premier job en
télé c'était dans une boîte de prod que
je dirais et ma rédaction chef ma chef
était beaucoup plus avec moi et je lui
plaisais bien elle était assez
insistante elle revenait beaucoup à la
charge pour aller boire un verre pour
qu'on discute etc et
de ne pas vouloir d'avoir de ne pas
avoir joué le jeu ne m'a pas on va dire
pour dire les choses sainement de ma
part je m'a pas aidé à faire carrière à
ce moment-là
[Rires]
mais c'est
pas de je pense que c'est dans tous les
métiers en fait qui a ce problème là et
c'est pas que vision et de notre époque
par rapport à avant alors la parole des
femmes c'est libérée et heureusement il
faut qu'elle se libère encore plus mais
c'est surtout qu'aujourd'hui il y a
aussi les agressions sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est-à-dire qu'avant
je voulais savoir si toi déjà pour ta
proposé pour une mission de télé ou quoi
c'est une évidence
c'est c'est des trucs pas et puis quand
tu dis non parce que tu fermes la porte
comme tu l'as très bien dit il y a des
gens qui arrivent à fermer la porte et
d'autres non et bah tu te retrouves
exclu de plein de choses alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]